Well howdy church, uh, around these parts.
We dress up at the end of every sermon series.
Can't get there. I'm sorry.
Um, this may be the first time in my life I've ever
worn anything with a horse on it.
Uh, and boots.
I clearly don't have the right jeans for it,
but, uh, both borrowed.
Uh, so what's the story here?
One of our deacons suggested that we make this
a cowboy spin today.
Uh, because he thought the bumper video music
that you just heard sounds like a spaghetti western.
And so, uh, I have no idea.
I've never watched one, so I'm gonna take his word for it.
That's where we're at with that today.
Uh, so anyway, that's why this is the way it is today.
So, but we are bringing our first things
first series to a close.
And we do dress up just not like this all the time.
But hasn't this been a fruitful study?
Uh, it has been for no one else but me at least,
but, uh, just such a, a life giving
deep dive into these doctrines.
As a reminder, we've been building our theological jar,
you might say over the last few weeks.
And, uh, you, you look at the, the big rocks,
the first things that we must agree on,
the things about God, the things about his word,
salvation about us, the,
the certain things about the end times.
We've put those big rocks in first, but
after that, we started to put these smaller rocks in.
That's clarifying some distinctions about our church.
Things that we would say kinda mark us off and,
and why there are churches and denominations
and they fit around the big rocks as you see.
Well, today we're gonna pour in some sand.
These are the less important doctrines of our faith.
These things that, that we as believers can differ on
and yet still be within the same church.
So what kind of things are we talking about here?
Well, these are in the church things, these beliefs,
topics like the timing of Jesus' return.
We got the big rocks on that.
But the timing of, of how that plays out, of course,
we can differ on and still be in the same church.
You've got style of music, you've got, uh, clothing choices
in the church that we can differ on and,
and we can still be together in the church.
But then it goes beyond that.
It, it goes into these things in our lives, daily life
that we would call areas of Christian liberty
or freedom that we have the choice to do this or not.
Now we're not talking about sin.
We'll get to that clearly, but, but what I choose to do
or not to do, we can differ on those things along the way.
So this is things like tattoos
or political parties that you might be a part of
or have a glass of wine at dinner or plastic surgery
or what holidays you choose to participate in
or not participate in.
You can see how we can
get different opinions on those things.
Yet the point is
that we are still together in the same church.
Now here's the thing. Even as I said, those things
gave those lists the what abouts popped up in your mind,
I'm sure, but, but what about, but,
but what about how do we apply that?
But, but what about this part of that?
What about, and and we see that that causes the debates.
Well, here's how we're gonna handle that.
I can't trace every single one of those in your mind,
of course, or every single issue that we would walk into.
But the reality is what we can do
is we can look into God's word for a framework on how
to handle those third level sand issues in
our lives that come up all the time,
every day, multiple times a day.
How do we decide what to do
or not to do as Christians with this freedom we have?
And first Corinthians eight
and nine is gonna help us get there.
And so turn there with me to
one Corinthians in the New Testament
and we're gonna start in one Corinthians eight verse one,
one Corinthians eight and nine.
Really we'll go through both chapters,
but we'll start in verse one of chapter eight.
Let me pray for us. God thank you
that your word does lead us.
It directs us. It gives us the ability to know you first.
That was the point. But then it also helps us know
what you want for us
and want from us in light of who you are.
And so as we look at at these things that
so often divide us in the world,
give us grace, give us unity.
Give us ways to walk together towards you.
Help us Holy Spirit.
We need you to lead and direct us to give us wisdom.
Help us in Jesus name. Amen. Amen.
So here's what I'm gonna argue today.
This is the, the thesis.
You might say this is the point that we are free in Christ.
Yes, but that freedom has limits.
We are free in Christ. Galatians five, one for freedom.
Christ has set us free.
Yet there are limits to that.
Now, as you hear that maybe some of us are even challenged
by that there's no limits
or maybe never thought about that at all.
Or maybe you have the wrong limits. Maybe you're,
you're putting too many strictures on
things maybe, I don't know.
My hope is that this is helpful to us all.
And so that's the question. Okay, what do you mean by
how our Christian liberty is limited?
How is it limited? What does God's word say?
Well, first it is limited by our love for believers
because we love other believers.
We limit our freedom.
Now, the Corinthian church had written the Apostle Paul a
letter at some point and they were asking a bunch
of questions about how to live the Christian life.
And one of those had to do with meat sacrificed to idols.
Should they eat it? Should they not?
Now why was that such a big deal?
Because throughout history, God had made it a big deal
that he commanded his people to avoid idolatry
in all kinds of every way they could.
And so to these people, now this was the process
of eating food that had been offered to an idol.
Was that right or wrong? Now they weren't offering it,
but somehow they obtained it through other means.
And so that that to them maybe towed the line of idolatry.
Should we or shouldn't we?
And there was a debate within the church about
how far a Christian should go in that some people,
their conscience felt like, yeah, I can eat that.
While other people felt like their conscience restricted
them from eating that meat.
And so they asked Paul, well here's
how the Holy Spirit inspired him to respond.
This is chapter eight verses one through 13.
Now, concerning food offered to idols,
meaning I'm responding to your question, we know that all
of us possess knowledge.
This knowledge puffs up. But love builds up.
If anyone imagines that he knows something he does not
yet know as he ought to know.
But if anyone loves God, he is known by God.
Therefore, as to the eating of food offered to idols,
we know that an idol has no real existence.
That there is no God but one for,
although there may be so-called Gods in heaven
or on earth, as indeed there may be many
gods and many lords.
Yet for us there is one God the Father from whom all things
and for whom we exist.
And one Lord Jesus Christ, through whom are all things
and through whom we exist.
He's tying it to a theological truth, right?
However, not all possess this knowledge,
but some through former association with idols eat food
as really offered to an idol.
And their conscience being weak is defiled.
Food will not commend us to God.
We're no worse off if we do not eat
and we're no better off if we do.
But take care that this right
of yours does not somehow become a stumbling block
to the weak for if anyone sees you
who have knowledge eating in an idol's temple,
will he not be encouraged if his I,
if his conscience is weak to eat food offered
to idols as well.
And so by your knowledge this weak person is destroyed the
brother for whom Christ died,
thus sinning against your brothers
and wounding their conscience.
When it is weak, you sin against Christ.
Therefore, if food makes my brother stumble,
I will never eat meat lest I make my brother stumble.
And so he's talking about this knowledge
as he's mentioned it a few times throughout
this little passage here.
This knowledge he referred to is,
is a Christian's understanding
that they're now not under the law anymore,
that they're free from, that they don't have
to follow all the regulations
that God has declared all the food out there clean.
Now they can eat it.
But notice again the context Intext.
Paul is primarily concerned with the unity of the church
for the building up
of the church in love toward one another.
And he says a couple ways that they were to do that.
First, that they were not
to stand in judgment over other people.
They were not to stand as believers in the church.
They were not to stand in judgment over others.
In fact, that's what verse eight says.
Look again, food will
not commend us to God.
We are no worse off if we do not eat.
And we're no better off if we do.
So there was a judgmental spirit within the Corinthian
church that actually was going both ways.
Those people who were abstaining from eating the food were
looking down on those who did eat the food
as if they were somehow compromising their faith.
And those who ate the food were looking down
on those who abstained.
Like they're weak in some way.
But Paul here says, neither of you are right
and neither of you are wrong.
You, you choose this or that.
Neither of you are right, neither of you are wrong.
In other words, if it's not a biblical command
at this point, it is post law, right?
It's not a biblical command anymore.
I have no right to say that what my conscience allows
yours should allow too.
Or what my conscience forbids yours should forbid as well.
And just think about how often that comes up in life
within the church, right?
Lemme just give you one simple example.
It's my personal conviction
that I'm not gonna drink alcohol at all.
But I can't stand here
and say to any of you of legal age that you can't
because my conscience says I can't.
Now what I can say, Ephesians five 18 says,
getting drunk is a sin.
So I can lean on that
and say, you, you should not get drunk.
That's a command of the Lord.
And just as a side note, I don't know
what blood alcohol content God says is drunk or not.
That's up to you. Like I don't know.
So that's between you and him.
But, but the point here is
that I can't impose my personal conviction on you.
And you can't stand in judgment over me
that I'm weaker in some way that I just chose not to, right?
That's the point he's making here.
'cause no one is closer to God if you do choose
to do something or if you don't choose to do something
that is a conviction issue.
But here's what that would've led to back then.
And so they're, they're reading this out loud to the church
and somebody's hearing him say these things.
And what that could have led to is that those
who are choosing the, the majority probably
who did eat the meat, they could have been hearing this
and started to feel like Paul was siding with them.
Like he's saying, man, all of us should eat.
Why would you not eat it?
I mean he, he's supporting all right to do this, right?
But did you notice what Paul did here?
He's focusing on love,
he's focusing on building up the church.
And so he quickly shifted to not just saying, Hey,
don't judge each other if you do or don't.
He also shifted to this, this encouragement
to avoid putting an obstacle in the way of other believers.
So yeah, don't stand in judgment.
You're closer to God, no, neither way.
But don't put an obstacle
in the way of one another.
This is what he says in verse nine, the scandal
of a stumbling block to the weak that those
who understood freedom in Christ saying, yeah, we can,
we have no qualms about it conscience wise.
They bulldozed over those
who didn't have that conviction.
And that word literally means to trip someone up that you,
you cause someone to fall.
It's a stumbling block in a, you might imagine a pathway
that there's a rock sticking up and that trips someone up.
That's what this word literally means.
It means someone who ha had come out of that world
of idolatry and that was sucking them in over and over
and they come to Christ and then they see a brother
or sister eating the same meat
that was just offered to the idol.
They might be tempted to fall right back into it.
And Paul says, you have to avoid that within the church.
Don't create obstacles for others. Now, now I know.
Listen, what happens really quickly when we hear something
like that with our libertarian tendencies in America,
we, we say, no, no, no.
Hold up. Somebody else's conscience is gonna limit me.
Really? That doesn't work. That doesn't work in America.
But, but notice, and by the way, just just as a side note,
chapter 10, you go read that later.
He does envision scenarios that you can eat the meat.
Like he's not saying it's impossible,
but look at how forcefully he says his point here in verses
11 and 12, look again at this
says, so by your knowledge this weak person is destroyed,
the brother for whom Christ died,
thus sinning against your brothers
and wounding their conscience.
When it is weak, you sin against Christ.
What he's saying is that if we really love our brothers
and sisters in Christ, why do we flaunt our freedoms?
Why do we not consider others that he says, are those
for whom Christ died to?
I don't think we ask those questions very often.
But he says,
our goal must be love for our brothers and sisters.
Not that we would knock them down in any way,
but that we would instead build them up.
Romans 14 and 15 says a lot of the same things,
but this is Romans 1420.
He says, do not for the sake of food,
destroy the work of God.
Everything is indeed clean,
but it is wrong for anyone to make another stumble by
what he eats in Romans 15, one and two.
We who are strong have an obligation to bear
with the failings of the weak not to please ourselves.
Let each of us please his neighbor for his good
to build him up.
See, the orientation of our hearts
as believers must be self-sacrificial.
It's what one Corinthians eight 13 said,
if meat makes my brother stumble, I'll never eat meat.
If fill in the blank choice decision makes my brother
stumble, I'm never gonna do it ever again.
That's the orientation in one Corinthians eight.
And so he's saying to us as the church internally,
this is the key element
that limits our freedom in Christ,
but it also is limited.
Our freedom in Christ is also limited by our love
for unbelievers.
So we just saw in one Corinthians eight, it's limited
by our love for one another in the church,
but then it's also limited here by our love for unbelievers.
There's a missional aspect of this limiting
of our Christian liberty, our freedoms as well.
So what he does in chapter nine is he lays out a long
defense of his ministry.
Paul's an apostle of Christ, he's spreading the gospel.
And so at that time,
and even today, he had every right
to take financial support as an apostle
and a minister of the gospel.
He, he absolutely could. He could have done that,
but he didn't in this context.
He didn't. And he explained why.
This is chapter nine, verse 12.
Skip ahead a little bit and see what he says.
He says, nevertheless, we have not made use of this rite,
but we endure anything rather than put an obstacle in the
way of the gospel of Christ.
Paul had a personal conviction
that taking financial assistance from the church
would hinder his gospel witness.
Now we might wonder, how does that work out?
Well, he, he, he saw it this way
that unbelievers might see him merely as a, a hired hand
that he's just preaching the gospel.
This, this message.
He's just preaching it to be, uh, to get a paycheck.
There's really no reason for him to do it.
Any other reason except
for in his mind he knew he was doing it merely
for the reward of Christ and for his pleasure.
But that's what he was saying to the church.
I don't wanna, I don't wanna create an obstacle
for anyone to hear the gospel.
And notice what he said in verse 12.
He would rather endure anything
than put an obstacle in the way of the gospel.
Anything poverty, beatings,
even death, anything.
I'll endure it for the sake of the gospel.
Now that that's piercing enough to us, right?
Like are we willing? But notice what he's saying in this.
His point here, he's saying, out of love for unbelievers,
we are not required to employ our rights
out of love for unbelievers.
None of us are required to utilize the rights
and freedoms that we have in Christ.
We're not required to you.
And I might be free to do this or free to do that of course.
But no one is saying we have to.
What Paul is illustrating here is that we can self limit
for the sake of the gospel spreading more.
Like have we ever thought that way
before that?
Just because I have the right
to say something on social media doesn't mean we have to.
That maybe I can limit myself.
Like yeah, I could say I can limit myself for the sake
of the gospel actually going forward.
And so people don't think I'm a jerk
and people don't think that Christians are certain ways
that we can limit that for the sake
of someone actually hearing the gospel instead
of just writing a song that just
because I can watch this show
or I can listen to that artist, no one is requiring me to
do you have the freedom to do it.
Yeah, okay. But not doing it might actually show
the world a different life.
Something's different about me, about our faith.
See, what Paul does is he examines his life
and he thinks about ways that people in his sphere
of influence would interpret what he's doing.
He's actually considering unbelievers
and saying, well, how would they better receive?
How would they better hear?
And what he does is he purposefully sets aside some
of his rights for the sake of the gospel.
Do we ever do that? Are we ever considering that?
Because here's, here's what
what I think maybe we we're steeped in this American culture
that our goal should not merely be
to live the most free lives we can in Christ.
That can't be the end game. That can't be the goal.
We should love one another.
But our goal also should be to fulfill this command
to serve our neighbors, this call
of God to serve our neighbors.
And this is what Galatians five says for you.
Were called to freedom brothers only.
Do not use your freedom as an opportunity for the flesh,
but through love.
Serve one another for the whole laws fulfilled in one word.
You shall love your neighbor as yourself.
Don't use it for selfish reasons. Use it to serve others.
And watch how Paul does it here in one Corinthians nine,
he sets aside his rights for the sake
of the gospel to love unbelievers.
And he says this, this is verses 19 through 23
in one Corinthians nine, for though I'm free from all,
I've made myself a servant to all that, I might win more
of them to the Jews.
I became a Jew in order to win Jews to those under the law.
I became as one under the law though not myself being under
the law, that I might win those under the law
to those outside the law.
I became as one, outside the law, not being outside the law
of God, but under the law of Christ that I might win those
outside the law to the weak.
I became weak that I might win the weak. I might.
I've become all things to all people that
by all means I might save some
and I do it all for the sake of the gospel that I may share
with them in its blessings.
Paul chose the hard way to be in the world,
but not of the world to be spiritually distinct
but not socially segregated.
And there's a tension in that. I understand.
Yes, there always is.
But what Paul advocated here for the purpose of the gospel
ministry, for the purpose of evangelism, he said,
I'm gonna be a servant to all,
even though I'm free from all I can do these things,
I'm gonna be a servant to all.
And notice how he did it.
He did it with those who were Jewish,
accommodating their sensitivities
to the degree he could to gain a hearing.
Like he wouldn't eat a pulled pork sandwich
in front of Jewish people.
Like that's just what he wasn't gonna do.
'cause he wanted them to listen to the gospel.
He did it with gentiles, with non-Jews
that those were outside the law.
He didn't expect them to act Jewish because they weren't.
He met 'em where they were.
He said, here's what we're about.
I'm not gonna bind up your conscience
with the law 'cause you're not under it.
Basically Paul was re was prepared to relinquish
whatever right was necessary
if doing so would cause unnecessary obstacles to the gospel.
He said, I'm gonna do whatever it takes apart from sin
to reach these people.
He was under the law of Christ.
What the Bible says is the royal law, the law of love,
what Jesus said is second only to loving God.
He says, my goal is to love my neighbor as myself.
That's the law of Christ.
And so just think about that for a second.
Do we love unbelievers enough to limit ourselves
so that they can see Jesus clearly through our lives
so they're not distracted by us?
Like are we considering their lives?
Are we considering where they stand?
Are we lovingly meeting where they are?
Are we seeking to love them
and serve them where they are,
what their thought process is, what their hangups are?
Are we caring enough for them? Now, hear me clearly.
I'm not saying we cave on our morals
or we we deny the truth of the gospel.
I'm not saying we sin so that we gain a hearing.
We don't behave like unbelievers.
We just identify with them as much as we can.
We meet them in their world.
We try to reach them by accommodating
and non sinful things to where we can know
that they are going to listen.
And we haven't put any stumbling blocks
in the way of them hearing the gospel.
So there's a couple limits, right?
There's our love for Christians, there's our love
for non-Christians.
Those are limits to our freedom.
There's actually a third limiting factor here
that we are limited by our love for Christ.
We are to limit our freedoms by our love for Christ.
This is the end of chapter nine.
He continues in verses 24 through 27, says,
do you not know that in a race all the runners run
but only one receives the prize?
So run that, you may obtain it.
Every athlete exercises self-control in all things
and they do it to receive a perishable w reef.
But we an imperishable. So I do not run aimlessly.
I don't box as one beating the air.
I discipline my body, keep it under control.
Lest after preaching to others,
I myself should be disqualified.
What he's saying by that, by using illustrations of
athletics, the Olympics sports,
what he's saying is now in Christ,
it's not just do whatever I wanna do now I just get
to do now have free, free to do whatever.
Right? That's not what he's saying.
No, he's saying our lives in Christ are
to be purposeful in everything we do.
Just like an athlete, there's self discipline.
Like if you want to run
and win, you have to be disciplined, you have
to have a direction, you have
to be purposeful in everything you do to be the best
and win the race.
So when we're considering freedom
decisions, couple questions.
As we live out this response to Christ's love
for us, how do we do it?
How do we choose wisely first? Does this spur growth?
I dunno, maybe it's the western theme that just brought this
to mind, but is, does this spur growth,
this whatever I'm about to do, the decision,
the the direction, the action, the the word,
does it spur growth in?
Does it? Does it provoke my spiritual maturity
and development in the Lord?
Does it stir my affections for Jesus
or does it hinder,
does it make me more like Jesus or not?
And and you think about, I'm like, what's our goal now
our goal is to please him.
Colossians says that our goal is to please the Lord,
to live a life pleasing to him.
What pleases him, obeying him,
growing in my ability to obey him.
That's what pleases him.
And so when I'm faced with a freedom decision, I need
to ask myself, does this point me more toward Jesus or not?
Does this make me more like Jesus or not?
That's a limiter to my freedom, right?
But there's something even bigger than that.
And it's the question that gets raised at the
end of chapter 10.
See, he's continuing to discuss this
eating meat or not question.
He applies it even magnifies it
by making this statement at the end of chapter 10.
The very last couple verses verse 31, he says,
so whether you eat or drink
or whatever you do, do all
to the glory of God whether you eat or not.
And in everything, your goal should be to glorify God.
That's the fundamental question above all else, what it does
to you, what it does to someone else.
The biggest question in all of this, does it glorify God
when you're faced with a decision, when you're faced
with a freedom option, does this glorify God?
Does it show the world around me that I'm a child of God,
that I have a new self within me, that my goal is
to represent God well, does it glorify him?
That decision will limit us.
Like when you start to think that way, you start
to think about how to glorify God in everything, man,
that's gonna limit some of the things we do, right?
Like if our number one goal was to please him,
not please ourselves, we'd be different.
And so here's how I wanna bring all this together,
this today to try to sum it all up to me,
flowcharts are beautiful.
I dunno if that's engineering background, but,
but I found this flowchart and our team made it look pretty.
So we're gonna put it up on this screen.
You might take a picture of it if you want,
but I wanna walk through this together
because this is gonna help us kind
of formulate a process of decision making.
It'll take everything we've just said
and it'll help us learn how to make decisions.
Again, at the top over all of it, you see,
do it all for the glory of God.
That's one Corinthians 10 31.
That should be number one over everything we do,
fundamental to our decisions.
But then you start left
to right and let's walk through this.
The first question, when you're faced with a decision to do
or not do or what you're gonna think about,
how you're gonna decide, does the Bible allow it?
If no, don't do it.
It seems pretty simple, right?
Like that should be foundational basic.
Sometimes we get tripped up with that one.
I know, but, but that should be first.
If the Bible says Don't do this, don't do it.
If the Bible does allow it though,
then then you ask the next question,
does my conscience allow it?
It may not be a biblical truth one way or the other,
but does my conscience, you should never,
we should never do something
that internally we feel is wrong.
And again, it may not be wrong for somebody else, but
but for me, I shouldn't go past that.
But if you're good there, what
that means then is you're in an area of Christian freedom.
But what we've done with that typically is
we've just thrown caution to the wind.
We just go for it. Yeah, my conscious allows it,
I'm just gonna go do it.
But I hope you've seen that's not the law of Christ, right?
It's not the way we should follow the Lord.
Instead, we need to ask three further questions.
Okay, you're an area of liberty, got that,
but what then first question,
what is its effect on other Christians?
'cause we just saw in one Corinthians eight,
love is more important than freedom.
Does this affect someone else?
Is this gonna hinder someone else's walk with Christ?
Second question. What is this effect on this activity
of this activity on non-Christians?
Is this gonna affect the witness that we have?
As one Corinthians nine said,
the gospel is more important than rights.
You have the right to do that,
but the gospel actually wins over that.
And then there's that third question, more personally,
what does this affect on my spiritual life?
I don't think we've said this enough.
Just because I can do something doesn't mean it's good.
We need to ask does just
because I can do this, does that mean it's good for me?
Everything is permissible, but not everything is beneficial.
See, that flow chart is how we can apply the mind of Christ
to the thousands of decisions that we make every day
to the decisions we make about our life
and where we're gonna go and how we're gonna do these
things here and there.
How to use wisdom to see the limits
of our freedom in the Lord.
And here's where all this comes to
in those freedom decisions,
in those third level things, there will be a variety
of ways that that plays out in the church among believers.
We will make different decisions.
We will see different conscience levels happen.
This helps us maintain unity in humility
and gentleness and patience and forbearance.
This is what he has given us in his word.
But that's gonna happen. There's gonna be differences.
And that's where a lot of the debates come.
And this is why I want to close the series with this today.
See, we've spent a couple months building this theological
jar, prioritizing the big rocks
of our faith, the essential doctrines, those things
that make us Christian.
The problem comes though,
whenever people will take those sand issues,
those third level things, those Christian freedom ideas,
those, those beliefs,
and they will become more passionate about those
than they do about the big rock doctrines
and will start to debate the sand issues way more.
We'll start to focus on
and divide over these kinds of things.
And we, we make these grains of sand seem really,
really huge in the end.
But here's what I wanna show you.
What happens whenever we put the sand in our jar
first, when we flip things
and we start putting preferential items in the church in
first we start putting Christian freedom ideas in first.
And we put the sand as top line items.
Like this is the most important thing.
And that becomes the crux of the matter.
We might even take these smaller rocks,
the second tier issues, the things
that we divide in churches over
and we kind of have different denominations
and and different churches.
And we may even start questioning people's salvation if
they're a part of a different church.
And we put that stuff in even more importantly.
And and then what happens to the big rocks?
Okay, well of course we realize and no, these are important.
Yes. And we might get a few of them
into our jar, but then
they don't all fit do they?
Like you start to see like, by the way, the same amount
of materials in that one as in this one,
but they don't fit
because it matters the order you put them in, right?
If you put the big rocks in first,
that's why we call this series.
First things first, the most important things,
the big rock items, we put them in first.
They should always be first.
And then we put the other stuff in around it and it fits.
We can never take for granted the big rocks of our faith
because they are the essential beliefs
that make us Christian.
They are the things that hold us all together. They will.
They are things that will sustain us for if we focus
on these less important matters as priorities,
we're gonna get all wrapped up
and divided those
decisions people make and we get all worked up about that.
The problem is that might cause us
to end up losing the big rocks.
May that never be so here, church.